ou ménage à domicile sur www.lalsace.fr
bonjour gaël le dantec
bonjour je suis michèle lundi politique
aujourd'hui absolument allons-y lundi
politique
gaël de dantec avec ses six cent mille
électeurs la réunion constitue un
réservoir de voix potentielles à ne pas
négliger est partie en campagne pour les
élections européennes le savent
après marie le pen pour son retour des
représentants d'europe écologie les
verts de passer quelques jours chez moi
il m'a fait courir
j'ai d'ailleurs at-elle cherché au menu
donc pour l'écologie et l'agriculture
gilet jaune carrière ne videra
glyphosate ou encore transport des
sujets autour d'écologie on ne manque
pas ici est confuse
ces questions aussi quelle place la
développement pour la région dans une
europe écologistes
comment convaincre les électeurs de se
déplacer quelles alliances dans le futur
parlement européen
david cormand secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie et autres invitent
d'habitude c'est l'invité qui étaient
soufflées c'est moi bonjour david
cormand bonjour merci d'être cette
invitation dans l'actualité il y a
aujourd'hui la restitution du grand
débat national
iliad ministre de l'écologie force de
justin est grosso t il ce combat avec
plus d'écologie plus david écologique le
français s'est bien entendu sous
françois de rugy a raison c'est que les
françaises et les français et au delà
des françaises et des français je pense
les habitants de notre planète sont de
plus en plus attentifs et soucieux de la
question écologique donc ça c'est vrai
après est ce que nos dirigeants actuels
sont à la hauteur de ses attentes et de
cette urgence
j'en suis pas sûr j'en suis pas sûre et
notamment ce gouvernement lorsqu'il
prend des décisions ne prennent pas des
décisions qui vont dans le sens du
niveau de changement qu'il faut opérer
que ce soit sur l'agriculture que ce que
cela soit sur la transition énergétique
cela soit dans ses relations avec un
certain nombre de lobbies de puissances
économiques installés qui elles n'ont
aucun intérêt à ce que ça change puisque
elle spécule sur la destruction de
l'environnement
c'est là qu'il faut choisir l'écologie
ce n'est pas que des déclarations
d'intention
c'est très bien de prendre conscience du
problème
il faut agir politiques globales ont
scandé quelque chose moi j'ai été déçu
par ce grand débat car je pense que le
mouvement social des gilets jaunes est
une formidable opportunité pour notre
démocratie pour nos dirigeants
dégoûté or j'ai eu le sentiment que le
président de la république n'a pas
vraiment écouté il a beaucoup parlé
beaucoup parler il a utilisé ce débat
pour se mettre en avant
alors que la tante je pense des nos
compatriotes de constituer nos
concitoyens c'est davantage de le voir
écouter que de l'entendre parler on se
souhaite une taxe écologique taxe sur le
carbone et à contribuer les jours nous
serons dans les rues ici à la réunion
dans les réunionnais que vous avez
rencontrées depuis quelques jours que
vous avez senti qu'il y avait peut-être
c'est une réticence 1 à payer plus pour
polluer moins
en fait je pense vraiment que ce qui
s'est passé avec le mouvement des gilet
jaune c'était pas du tout un refus de
l'écologique y compris un refus des
efforts à faire pour l'écologie c'est le
sentiment d'avoir dire pourquoi de
ressentir que pourquoi ça tombe toujours
sur les mêmes les efforts c'est ça qui
est injuste je suis favorable à la
fiscalité carbone
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le réel coût de
l'utilisation du carbone est colossal et
donc il faut lui donner un coût réel le
problème c'est quand on met en place
cette fiscalité carbone
on peut pas laisser les gens captifs de
leur voiture ça que les gens disent mais
moi je suis un contribuable captifs je
ne peux pas faire de l'évasion fiscale
je suis obligé de me servir de la
voiture et c'est pour ça vous fiscalisés
la voiture et avec les recettes de cette
fiscalité vous ne me donnez pas les
moyens
de me passer de cette voiture donc là il
ya une forme de promesses intenables de
deals de troquer de deals léonard comme
un contrat léonin où il ya deux rapports
de force qui sont pas les mêmes je pense
que la grande erreur du pouvoir actuel
quand il a mis en place cette fiscalité
carbone c'est de ne pas dire on file
scalise le carbone non fiscalise pas
uniquement les petits ont fiscalise
aussi les gros le kérosène le fioul
lourd et la totalité de ses recettes
fiscales
c'est soit pour vous accompagner vers la
sortie de l'utilisation de la voiture
soit on meurt en place des transports
collectifs vous soyez moins dépendants à
la voiture et l'ont justement être
d'élite quand mon secrétaire nationale
d'europe écologie les verts est candidat
aux européennes cinquième sur la liste
ça est notre invité son père jusqu'à 13
ans posez vos questions au 0262 99-2000
politique du transport dont vous parlez
à l'ensemble vous avez fait trembler
circulé ces derniers jours la réunion
trois mots pas au tampon quoi et pour
cause ouais alors justement c'est quoi
la solution vous parler d'eux c'est
compliqué pour les automobilistes qui
paie cher les camions ainsi c'est ainsi
qu'en métropole et avant vos solutions
alternatives
d'abord je pense qu'il faut prendre
conscience vous le savez je suis
métropolitain et c'est la première fois
que j'ai à la réunion donc j'entends pas
ici de donner des leçons du tout mais je
pense qu'il ya une injustice original
d'avoir voulu greffer en fonctionnement
pour le coup metropolit a avec un très
gros usage de la voiture au territoire
de la réunion qui était pas forcément un
territoire pour son avenir c'est une
bonne chose de faire ça et je pense que
l'invasion par dont l'inflation et
l'invasion d'ailleurs 2 d'augmentation
de route n'apportera pas de solution
durable aux problèmes de circulation qui
assure cette île partout dans le monde
à chaque fois qu on a rajouté des routes
ça rajoute et les embouteillages vers la
solution c'est quoi la solution c'est
petit à petit de voir comment on
réorganise l'urbanisation pour avoir une
densification plus grande de l'habitat
il c'est de mettre en oeuvre
progressivement des transports
collectifs pour que les gens qui
aujourd'hui son budget dans un foyer
d'avoir deux voitures puissent au moins
se passer d'une voiture ça c'est
beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat en moyenne
une voiture ça coûte entre eux le modèle
que vous avez
une voiture moyenne entre 300 et 600
euros par mois donc quand vous passer de
deux à une voiture parce qu'on a mis en
place des alternatives en termes de
transports dont vous avez besoin d'une
voiture vous gagnez le du pouvoir
d'achat et ça fait une voiture ça limite
de 50% les voitures qui est en
circulation
et petit à petit vous résorber le mono
transport actuel qui est celui de la
voiture vous entendu cette année vous
exprimer avec marie toussaint que les a
convaincus quatrième sur la liste vous
entendus sur la question des carrières
nécessaire pour ceux du champ qui la
nouvelle route du littoral
ils ont beaucoup entendu parler le
français qu'at-elle qui n'est prévu pour
l'instant vous qu'il est encore possible
de faire évoluer
j'espère en tout cas je l'espère parce
que bon c'est pas un secret nous en tant
qu'écologiste ont été défavorables à
cette nouvelle route du littoral est
c'est fait nous avons perdu sur ce
combat là nous ce que nous disons
maintenant c'est qu'il faut peut-être
pas s'entêter persister à faire ce
dernier coûteront 100 sous forme de
digues pour deux raisons c'est parce que
si on fait une digue plutôt qu'un
l'aqueduc au viaduc olympiens tu prends
donc si on fait une digue saab deux
effets négatifs
1 un plus gros impact sur le littoral
parce que du coup c'est pas pareil des
pylônes que si on sait un comblement à
100% avec une digue
donc c'est beaucoup de matériaux qu'on
met à la mer et qu'il faudrait plus
impactés l'écosystème et surtout il va
falloir faire des carrières ces
carrières qui sont en train d'être fait
et qui vont défigurer défiguré le
patrimoine naturel de cette île et ça
c'est un crève coeur on a rencontré les
différents collectifs hier qui se
battent 1 sur l'histoire de ces
carrières et c'est un déchirement de
voir franchement je crois aujourd'hui
qu'on est des clivages anciens sont un
peu dépassé les clivages aujourd'hui
qu'on allait y compris politique c'est
celui des destructeurs
d'un côté il ya ceux qui spéculent sur
la destruction de l'environnement
et il ya les terriens et nous hier on a
rencontré toutes ces jours on a passé
des terriens au sens où attaché à la
terre avoir un économie un mode de vie
qui est attachée à la réalité terrestre
et en face d'eux ils ont des lobbys
énorme qui eux font de l'argent sur la
destruction
donc voilà cette route on va être fini
moi je dit juste c'est ce qu'on peut
prendre le temps de réfléchir et plutôt
que faire cette digue
qui va avoir un impact colossal que vont
payer les générations futures est ce
qu'on peut faire quelque chose qui sera
moins impactants pour l'environnement et
pour épauler de la réunion aujourd'hui
même les voitures électriques réunion
sont donc essentiellement film on
recharge et de l'énergie qui provient
d'énergies fossiles charbon fioul
qu'est ce que peut faire l'europe parce
que c'est quand même pour ce que vous
êtes là qu'est ce que peut faire
l'europe pour que la réunion de l'ain se
déplace sans alourdir son bien carbone
d'abord je pense qu'il faut se garder de
l'idée que remplacer le parc automobile
actuel thermique par de l'électrique est
une bonne idée parce que ça pose plein
de problèmes vous avez parlé de la
production d'électricité mais on peut
parler aussi des batteries qui elle
aussi à produire créer énormément de
nuisances environnementales c'est les
mines de lithium etc qui de quitter
nickel qui détruisent l'environnement
donc vraiment qu'on puisse raisonner en
disant on va tous continuer avec le même
mode de vie où quelque part mon
autonomie est garantie par mon
automobile
la véritable autonomie de demain pour
les citoyens le citoyen c'est justement
de ne plus être dépendant de leur
voiture nous le projet qu'on propose
pour l'europe et pour l'ensemble des
territoires européens qui sont rattachés
d'une certaine façon à l'europe et la
réunion évidemment on fait partie c'est
comment on change de modèle comment on
fait en sorte qu' on puisse continuer à
avoir un niveau de vie
même un meilleur niveau de vie en
changeant de mode elle est donc modèle
que nous on prône c'est un autre modèle
énergétique
d'abord on économise l'énergie donc
moins de transports individuels
motorisés moins de maisons qui sont pas
isolés et qui du coup soit on dépense de
l'argent alors quand il fait froid avec
des chauffages quand il fait chaud comme
ici avec la climatisation comme on
change ça on passe à la sobriété
énergétique et ça fait faire des
économies et la deuxième modèle c'est
comment on produit de l'énergie
autrement et là encore une fois sur un
territoire comme la réunion il ya des
ressources naturelles renouvelables pour
le potentiel pour produire de l'énergie
j électrique à ne pas savoir qu'en faire
c'est poté ça tout le monde a l'air
d'accord d'accord progrès en ce sens là
tout le monde a l'air d'accord mais le
monde n'est pas d'accord
vous savez la france c'est la deuxième
façade maritime du monde notamment grâce
aux territoires d'outre-mer
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune éolienne
offshore connecter au réseau pour toute
la france alors que d'autres pays moins
exposés avec au moins deux territoires
marins comme l'allemagne comme le
danemark ont considérablement développé
ce savoir faire là donc là il ya tout le
monde a l'air d'accord mais quand il
s'agit de passer à l'acte pour la france
en tout cas ce sont des lobbys installés
qui préfèrent total pour pas les nommer
qui préfèrent continuer à spéculer sur
ce qu'il maîtrise bien
c'est à dire l'énergie carbone il ya un
autre lobby important en france qui
s'appelle edf qui lui c'est plutôt
spécialisé sur la question nucléaire de
production électrique et qui du kunar
vesti pas suffisamment pour le
renouvelable et pourtant le renouvelable
c'est un autre avantage autre que
l'aspect environnemental c'est qu'on
peut produire et distribuer au niveau
local et donc typiquement pour une île
l'énergie d'origine renouvelable
c'est une bénédiction et donc c'est un
crève coeur qu'on ne développe pas
davantage cette production et celles de
distribution d'énergie dont le
changement climatique un des enjeux que
vous mettez en avant pendant votre votre
campagne que vous et mais vous notamment
petit temps que moi c'est vraiment
concernés par les effets par les causes
de ce réchauffement climatique on peut
se dire moi et toi
un confetti c'était moi depuis quatre
jours que je suis arrivé tous les jours
on m'a parlé plusieurs fois de la
période de sécheresse qu'on est en train
de rencontrer à la rue ça voilà vous
avez un premier impact qui est pas
secondaire ça leur parle de la ressource
à l'eau il n'y a pas de vie possible
pour la nature et pour l'humain sans eau
et donc justement parce que la réunion
est une île elle et j'ai envie de dire
encore plus vulnérable que le reste de
la terre et donc s'il ya des territoires
qui sont particulièrement impacté par le
changement climatique
c'est des territoires comme des îles
parce que c'est pour que la vie trouve
son chemin sur une île comme la réunion
mais c'est vrai pour toutes les îles il
a fallu des centaines de milliers
d'années d'hazard incroyable pour que
des graines d'arbres arrive jusque là
que l'arbre pause qu'il crée un
écosystème et le problème du changement
climatique au delà du climat qui
modifient c'est qu'il a un impact
décisif sur les écosystèmes et
l'écosystème du nil il est encore plus
fragile que l'écosystème sur le
continent et donc l'impact du changement
climatique sur ce qui permet la vie sur
l'île de la réunion
il va être colossal et donc oui il faut
avoir une action pour limiter le
changement climatique mais vous avez
raison c'est pas l'échelle de la réunion
qu'on va réussir à changer la courbe du
changement climatique au niveau
planétaire par contre ce que peut faire
l'île de la réunion c'est anticiper ces
changements pourraient être un
territoire résilient au moment où ces
changements voire à gré et pouvoir
continuer à y vivre dans des bonnes
conditions
vous êtes votre séjour ici l agriculture
est ce que vous avez appris qu est ce
que vous avez retenu et et en quoi
est-ce que ça peut figurer dans un
programme urbain deux choses la première
chose que j'ai compris c'est que la
réunion c'est le deuxième département
français vont pardonner par le
département de l'intérieur français qui
utilisent le plus de l'ifo that he le
pesticide
ça c'est quelque chose auquel il faut
remédier vous savez on a mis en oeuvre
et encore une fois il faut l'interdire
oui il faut interdire même si les règles
de son après 2006 il a d'abord il ya des
produits de substitution dans l'existant
et j'ai pu rencontrer avant-hier un
couple qui a converti son exploitation
de 5 hectares
de cannes à sucre en bio parce que ils
se seront ils ont eu le flash le
chlordécone en 2015 ils sont dit on peut
pas continuer dans des codes qui la
culture de bananes aux antilles oui
c'est ça et s'arrêter mais c'était le le
le comment dire le déclencheur d'une
prise de conscience et du coup ils sont
passés en bio et is an ils réussissent à
s'en sortir financièrement parce que ils
procèdent eux mêmes à la transformation
d'un cadre acier la canne à sucre en
pain de sucre en sirop de canne etc etc
et du coup ça permet aussi de dégager
des recettes supplémentaires
moi ce que je crains c'est que le modèle
un peu mono activité agricole de la
réunion qui est la canne à sucre est de
plus en plus si j'ai bien compris la
canne à sucre fibre cia pour produire
non pas de l'alimentation mais de l'état
n'a jusque là pas de l'agrocarburant je
pense que c'est une mauvaise idée enfin
yaya la nécessité et pas seulement la
réunion partout de redonner une
destination vivrières à nos terres
agricoles et produire en circuit court
pour qu'il y ait le moins possible des
changes transnationaux ça fait des
économies locales plus résiliente j'ai
entendu aussi qu'il ya des problèmes
importants de diabète à la réunion qui
est notamment liée à un mode alimentaire
très carnet de plus en plus carnet alors
qu'il ya les ressources disponibles en
termes de ressources naturelles pour
faire des productions locales de fruits
et légumes c'est bon pour la santé c'est
bon pour l'économie locale
c'est bon pour l'environnement parce que
ce sont des productions qui peuvent se
faire en bio 101 des pesticides et
intrants et donc je pense que c'est
vraiment un modèle qui est gagnant
gagnant faire attention que comment dire
ce qu'on assigne comme modèle économique
à la réunion se fasse pas au détriment
des réunionnaises et des réunionnais je
pense que trop souvent le continent la
métropole a été prescripteurs d'un
modèle de économique qu'on ne pensait
très intelligent jus de paris et qui
finalement à desservir le territoire de
la réunion c'est de cela dont il faut
sortir et l'europe a une responsabilité
par rapport à ça c'est surtout ces
territoires retrouve un modèle
économique qui soit plus construit sur
les terroirs sur les territoires plutôt
que sur une planification généralistes
qui c'est qui s'est développé autour des
propos de yannick jadot qui la tête de
lice amour que je les verts qui s'est
dit enfin avoir finalement l'économie de
marché entreprise pour une ovation il ya
du coutal accusée par la gauche d'être
de droite d'être flux très libéral
droite gauche les notions que vous
considérez aussi fait débat c'est parce
que il s'agit là du doigt
c'est intéressant ce débat parce que moi
je crois dans les valeurs humanistes de
la bouche et je combats le modèle
économique libéral de la droite après la
gauche dompter héritière l'écologie
politique c'est pas la gauche
d'inspiration marxiste c'est à dire sur
l'économie uniquement administrés sans
aller sur jusqu'au caricature des
kolkhozes que sage mais une économie où
finalement les choses sont décidées de
façon autoritaire et surtout son
productiviste en tant qu'écologiste moi
je suis opposé au capitalisme
d'abord parce qu'il génère des
inégalités sociales et parce qu'il était
question que c'est parce qu'une autant
c'est parce qu'on retrouve les vélos
estime à ce que l'économie de marché que
nous nous souhaitons séné comme une
image et une économie marché qui soit
extrêmement régulier ce que les
écologistes défendent comme modèle
économique depuis leur origine ce qu'on
appelle une économie plurielle c'est
l'économie coopérative c'est l'économie
sociale et solidaire c'est l'économie
circulaire c'est les filières courtes
c'est les amap les association de
maintien de l'agriculture paysanne et
c'est une économie c'est les services
publics et c'est aussi une économie de
marché mais pas celle qu'on est en train
de subir aujourd'hui qui n'est plus de
l'économie de marché en réalité c'est
une économie capitaliste financiarisé
qui tourne le dos à la réalité du marché
dit spéculent sur des marchés imaginaire
donc ça c'est plus l'économie c'est
autre chose c'est la financiarisation de
notre modèle économique que nous
combattons nous combattons ces lobbys
eva joly députée européenne pourchasse
monsieur juncker qui est l'ancien
premier ministre du luxembourg et qui
favorise président l'opération le
président de la commission maintenant et
qui favorise les paradis fiscaux
et donc nous dans ce cadre nous avons
choisi un camp mais ce que nous pensons
c'est pour combattre justement
efficacement le capitalisme c'est pas le
modèle de la gauche du xxème siècle qui
peut le battre
si un nouvel imaginaire
politique c'est une certaine façon si on
veut se mettre d'accord sur les mots la
gauche du 21e siècle est pour nous la
gauche du 21e siècle c'est l'écologie
politique
ça peut pas être génération ça peut
paraître pense qu'à un moment toutes ses
forces devront être en mesure de faire
une coalition majoritaire si on veut
combattre l'extrême droite et le
libéralisme incarné pour monsieur macro
pour parler vite après je crois que la
différence entre l'écologie politique
que nous incarnons et ses autres forces
que moi je respecte c'est qu'elles
viennent d'une doxa idéologique que je
peux dont je parlais tout à l'heure
monsieur gluges panneaux monsieur à main
c'est un héritage de ce qu'on appelle la
social-démocratie la social démocratie
c'est un modèle politique qui a plutôt
pas mal fonctionné tant qu'il y avait la
croissance sauf que maintenant il n'y
aura plus la croissance qu'on a connu
certains que pendant les trente
glorieuses et après on a détruit
l'environnement pour créer de la
croissance ça marchait très bien c'est
sur le mode herbe le modèle de
développement que essentiel bien sûr
c'est essentiel c est ce qu on continue
comme avant avec des aménagements à la
marge ou est-ce qu'on change de modèle
nous nous disons qu'il faut tout changer
tout doit changer si on veut maintenir
la vie sur terre
tout doit changer il a une des premières
choses qui doit changer c'est notre
relation à la nature est inventé
l'économie du 21e siècle c'est inventer
une économie qui est compatible avec le
maintien de la vie sur terre c'est pas
un petit sujet c'est un sujet
existentielle j'ai même envie de dire
pour la borne haute civilisation donc
possible pour ces élections
ça fait 30 ans est passé par là parce
que ça fuse
vu confier par contre après dans un très
intéressant parce qu'aujourd'hui je paye
trop loin tu mais il faut comprendre que
parlement européen les familles
politiques organisés au sein du groupe
il ya deux ou trois groupes plutôt
rangée à l'extrême droite encore une
cinquantaine chacun d'eurodéputés ça ça
devrait bouger parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de forces d'extrême droite qui sont en
train de se développer en europe il ya
un gros bloc qu'on appelle le bpe c'est
la droite
donc ça va des démocrates-chrétiens
jusqu'à monsieur romanes et ses amis qui
plus tôt lui très adroite en pourtant
etc voilà essentiellement piloté par
angela merkel et voilà c'est les
allemands sont très dominant dans cette
affaire il ya un autre bloc un peu plus
petit qui est celui des sociaux
démocrates dont je parle est donc en
france socialiste socialiste à il ya un
blog qui est celui des libéraux donc là
dans cette famille là ils sont une
soixantaine il ya des gens très très
libéraux y en a d'autres un peu plus
ouvert et là ça sera éventuellement la
famille politique dans laquelle israël
et macro nist qui n'y sont pas pour
l'instant qui couvre aujourd'hui ne sont
pas mais ce qui sera accepté ou pas sont
gras il ya la gauche la gauche logique
unitaire européenne ou là dedans il ya
une cinquantaine soixantaine
d'eurodéputés
cela va des amis de monsieur mélenchon
qui peuvent être un peu écolo à do you
know son argile dont liu ce régime et
connaissait bien si oui très écologiste
et avec qui d'ailleurs on a travaillé
parlement repères avec beaucoup sur
beaucoup de dossiers quatrième sur la
liste de 70 semaines et j'espère nation
qui sera lui même s'il est sur un multi
ce que la note il a fait un très bon
boulot et il ya dans ce groupe là aussi
par contre dés
élus issus des partis communistes plutôt
productiviste plutôt favorable au
charbon eyal groupe des verts et le
groupe des verts et des régionalistes
c'est un groupe assez charnière où on
est aujourd'hui 52 et mon pain 7 65 70 à
l'issue des prochaines élections
européennes qui peut être charnière dans
cette histoire il faut comprendre
jusqu'à maintenant l'union européenne
elle était dirigée par une coalition des
sociaux-démocrates avec la droite sur le
ppe et le parti socialiste européen est
en gros il est des compromis pour
conduire l'europe l'europe telle qu'on
connaît et sait ce statu quo auquel il
faut mettre un terme
il faut qu'on change de il ya trois
options pour l'europe
est ce qu'elle se rendrait ce qu'elle se
maintient dans ce statu quo un peu
libérale est ce qu'il ya une nouvelle
majorité de la droite droitiser avec
l'extrême droite
ou est ce qu'il ya une nouvelle
coalition qui permet qu'elles soient
plus écolo plus solidaire plus
démocratique et c'est ce qu'on va
essayer de faire pour après le 26 mai
est ce que vous prenez un engagement
avant ces élections de avec qui vous
vous alliez ray ou avec qui vous n'avez
pas je peux le faire sauf que c'est
compliqué c'est pas pour faire la langue
de moi mais admettons qu'on a le choix
entre laisser faire une coalition droite
plus extrême droite comme c'est le cas
en autriche comme c'est le cas dans
d'autres pays européens
et c'est extrêmement dangereux si on a
le choix entre ça une coalition même
avec des gens de droite qui permet
d'éviter de donner l'europe à l'extrême
droite
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire moi
aujourd'hui tant qu'on n'a pas le
résultat des élections européennes c'est
des engagements un peu léger de dire à
moi je peux vous dire merci
sauf ceux qui savent déjà qu'ils
s'alliant avec personne mais le sens de
l'europe pour qu'on a gagné par exemple
les verts on a gagné avec nous selon
raji d'ailleurs sur la pêche électrique
sur la pêche en eau profonde
or ce qu'on a construit des coalition y
compris avec des eurodéputés de droite
et j'ai entendre quand la france
insoumise di a nou jamais on travaillera
avec la droite
la cie younous omarjee il l'a fait il a
bien fait il l'a fait avec nous avec des
socialistes avec d'autres pour gagner
une majorité d'idées pour sauver les
océans est donc ce qui se passe au
parlement européen nous n'avons france
n'a pas cette culture là on n'a pas une
culture de coalition a une culture très
majoritaire avec le présidentialisme
quoi et la culture parlementaire qui
permet sur des coalitions de gagner des
dossiers de fond
essentiel pour notre démocratie nous on
se défilera pas sûr qu'on est très
radicaux sur changement d'europe qu'on
veut faire et donc on veut changer les
traités mais dans les traités actuels et
dans les coalitions telles qu'elles
pourront se faire on voudra quand même
être efficace et agir pour gagner des
combats après il s'agit pas de renoncer
aux idéaux il s'agit de dire quand on
peut gagner typiquement sur la fin du
massacre des fonds des océans
il faut aller chercher des majorités
pour gagner ça vous avez évoqué les
régionalistes qui sont avec vous il ya
aussi sur votre liste les corses hewitt
11 oh quelle vision est ce que vous avez
ce que doit être le degré d'autonomie
des records comme la réunion c'est
intéressant le terme d'autonomie
d'ailleurs moi je crois que encore une
fois c'est un regard je le dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité ça regard extérieur
ans c'est pas moi d'expliquer ce qu'il
faut faire
aux réunionnaises et réunionnais mais je
crois qu'ils auraient beaucoup à gagner
à développer le sens d'une identité
spécifique à ce territoire je crois que
trop souvent la réunion était conçu je
parle de la part de la france en de
pareils et comme une extension de la
france sans prendre en compte ce que
disent être un peu tout à l'heure les
réalités de ce territoire là et qui
mieux que les réunionnaises et les
réunionnais peuvent comprendre les
interactions les constructions les
réseaux d'économie locale à faire par
exemple quelque chose qui m'a intéressé
dans les discussions que j'ai eues c'est
que les échanges économiques de la
réunion c'est beaucoup avec l'europe
avec la métropole alors qu'il ya un
écosystème économique plus proche que ça
soit madagascar parce que l'afrique du
sud que ce soit les morisques sage qui
est
comment dire pas suffisamment développée
et ça pour quoi parce que les gens qui
ont pensé comment fallait faire c'est
pas des gens d'ici et donc l'autonomie
des réunionnaises et des réunionnais je
parlais pas lavés l'autonomie politique
c'est l'autonomie en tant que citoyen en
tant qu'être vivant en tant que comment
je gère ma zone de subsistance de quoi
je suis dépendante comment je suis plus
indépendant par rapport à ce qui vient
de l'extérieur c'est ça passe aussi par
une forme d'autonomie politique du
territoire et c'est pour ça que nous
sommes très à l'aise de travailler avec
nos amis bretons avec nos amis corses et
gilles simeoni qui préside la la région
enfin la région j'ai pas comment
l'appeler lui c'est quasiment pays mais
la corse
parce que c'est pas dans une vision
fermée et refermée sur elle-même
par exemple vous savez nos amis corses
étaient les premiers à vouloir
accueillir l'aquarius alors qu'il ya un
vent mauvais qui souffle en europe qui
ce bateau qui est qui recueillit
réfugiés seulement alors que la france
voulait pas le faire là la corse a dit
nous on est prêt à accueillir l'espagne
voulait pas le faire l'accord film où
nous sommes prêts à l'accueillir et qu
il ya une vraie combinaisons possibles
entre un sentiment d'identité et
d'attachement à territoire et en même
temps l'ouverture sur le monde et de ce
que j'en comprends c'est aussi un peu
l'histoire de l'île de la réunion
l'autre demie c'est le droit pour la
réunion ne pas appliquer ces directives
européennes qui sont jugés comme très
concrètes y compris son environnement la
con je crois pas que ça soit l'écologie
qui rajoute des contraintes
moi je crois que c'est l'absence d'
écologie qui renforce les contraintes en
réalité quand on a un maire qui n'est
plus respirable
quand on peut plus se déplacer autrement
qu'en voiture quand on a pu accès à
l'eau potable
quand on n'a plus accès à des aliments
de qualité qui sont pas traitées c'est
là la perte d'autonomie et la perdre
et la véritable contrainte bien sûr il
doit y avoir une capacité à la clé des
législations qui n'ont pas de sens à
l'échelle du nîmois je suis d'accord
avec ça mais je suis plus je le
tournerai en positif si vous voulez moi
je crois vraiment que des territoires
comme une réunion devrait avoir un droit
supérieur à ce que c'est aujourd'hui à
l'expérimentation dire de pouvoir
expérimenter des choses différentes
qu est ce qu est la norme ailleurs mais
je tomberai pas de façon négative
je pense qu'il faut plutôt faire adroit
augmenter si on veut permettre de faire
mieux mais pas forcément de se dispenser
et d'autoriser à faire moins bien que
vous savez avec cette logique là c'est
comme ça que l'on parlait des antilles
du chlordécone c'est un scandale en
réalité c'est comme ça qu'on a continué
à utiliser des insecticides qu'on savait
qu'ils étaient mortels sur les
territoires d'outre-mer au nom de faire
des normes environnementales plus légère
ça a été au bénéfice de qui à la fin des
habitants des antilles ou de ce qui
faisait le commerce des bananes et quand
j'entends qu'à la réunion alors je sais
plus le nom de la maladie n'est qu'on
continue à commercialiser la viande de
boeuf qui a été touché par de grosses
bobines exactement alors que sur le
continent
hors métropole c'est pas commercialisé
sallèles à la réunion ces salles
assouplissement des normes qu'on
voudrait on voit bien que c'est cet
assouplissement des normes dans ce sens
là ça c'est un manque de considération
par rapport à ces territoires
je crois qu'au contraire les territoires
d'outre-mer au bon endroit plus de
considération au delà de des questions
d'environnement les dérèglements des
natives qui concerne l'environnement
pour payer une partie des réunionnais
défense et peut-être plus encore vers
l'europe office de machine
bureaucratique lointaine qui prend pas
en compte la réalité locale qui a imposé
les armes ah ben non seulement je le
comprends mais je pense la même chose
dire que le problème de l'europe vous
dire c'est à la fois une opportunité
extraordinaire c'est aussi quelque chose
qui s'est fait trop longtemps sans les
citoyens et à un moment quand vous
faites les choses sans les citoyennes et
citoyens
vous finissez pas le faire contre eux
roger puisque c'est à dire il faut
redonner la souveraineté démocratique à
l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est une technocratique qui
fonctionnent quasiment tout seul et donc
il faut retrouver le sens ne pourquoi on
a fait l'europe
l'europe on l'a fait c'était la promesse
de la paix et de la prospérité
je crois qu'il faut un nouveau rêve
européen à ce rêve européen nous les
écoles on dit que c'est l'élément
fédérateur c'est l'écologie politique
c'est que l'europe doit permettre de
faire de l'écologie et notre vision à
nous les verts de l'écologie c'est le
lien justement avec ses territoires et
l'europe doit plus être uniquement une
machine vous parliez des normes à normes
et à normaliser à uniformiser c'est au
contraire une institution qui me permet
de respecter de renforcer les
particuliers concrètement comment
trouvez-vous luz exemple comment est ce
qu'on y met plus de parlement c'est
aujourd'hui le parlement européen
il a un rôle très souvent consultatif là
où elle pouvoir c'est pas au parlement
européen c'est au conseil rassemblement
des chefs d'état ou des chiens le
conseil et le parlement ne bois et la
commission à la fin il ya la commission
qui sont aussi l'objet d'un deal entre
les pays
donc il ya un vide de souveraineté
aujourd'hui quand on élit nos dirigeants
nationaux on les dirait rené nelli pas
pour diriger l'europe
les élites pour diriger par exemple la
france aussi on est français là il faut
que les parlementaires européens est
davantage de pouvoir et qu'ils ont plus
de pouvoir et que c'est eux qui à la
faune le final cut sur la décision
finale sur eux ce qui engage l'europe
ils seront forcément plus responsable
devant les citoyennes et citoyens
européens ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose c'est que je pense qu'il
faut simplifier et rendre plus
transparent tout ce qui est financement
européen là depuis j'ai ici je suis ici
j'ai visité plein d'endroits où il ya le
gros stickers de fil par l'union
européenne parce qu'il ya plein de
financement qui passe mais on me dit à
chaque fois c'est très compliqué à
pêcher près deux milliards d'euros qui
siffle tout à fait rien sauf que l'on
sait pas trop comment ces flux se font
beaucoup de gens qui veulent y avoir
droit comprennent pas la chaîne de
décision sur qui décide quoi et c'est le
manque de transparence ça crée aussi un
éloignement de citoyenneté le troisième
élément c'est ce que
j'essaie de développer sur nous les
verts nous sommes pour une europe
fédérale mais une europe des régions une
robe des territoires une robe des
terroirs que pour nous l'état nation
quelque part et un espace politique
intéressant mais qui est pas décisif ce
qui est décisif c'est la vision globale
agir à l'échelle de l'europe c'est avoir
la masse critique y compris au niveau
géopolitique pour peser sur la marche du
monde
mais pour être heureux en tant que
citoyen c'est entités européennes
elle doit avoir comme point de mire
avant tout les territoires au niveau
local c'est comme ça aussi je pense
qu'on renforce la fluidité la démocratie
européenne des victoires moi ce que vous
pensez vraiment pour être audible dans
cette période de crise sociale où vous
les difficultés les fins de mois alors
pour surveiller ses autres du monde
c'est impossible mais c'est une réalité
vous l'avez peut-être pas celui là c'est
très étrange parce que j'ai rencontré
martin nourris qui est gilet jaune sur
les figures de gillot c'était très
intéressant comme
comme discussions c'est que justement il
ya une conscience très aiguë du lien
entre la détresse sociale et le mépris
social aussi quelque chose qui est
ressenti avec beaucoup de force
au-delà de la question sociale au sens
propre même si elle compte y ait le
sentiment le mépris d'abandon du fait
que les décisions sont prises parce qu'
une écoute à leur sens nous contre nous
et le lien avec la question démocratique
et la question écologique
c'est notamment elle en parle je trouve
très bien de quoi je suis dépendant pour
assurer pour avoir la main sur mon
avenir
quand on parle de ça de la question de
subsistance c'est une question
écologique en réalité et c'est par
hasard si au même moment il ya eu ce
mouvement social d gilet jaune et le
mouvement des marchés pour le climat et
c'est par hasard c'est dans beaucoup
d'endroits ces deux mouvements sociaux
ont convergé sur des analyses sur les
analyses qui sont elles aussi
convergentes ce que je pense qu'il est
très nouveau justement c'est que pour
beaucoup de jusqu'à présent on dit ouais
mais l'écologie c'est un truc plus
riches c'est les bobos c est riche qu'on
le temps de se préoccuper de l'écologie
ceux qui sont vraiment dans la mouise
ils n'ont plus le temps ils n'ont pas le
temps de s'occuper de ça ce qui est très
nouveau c'est qu'aujourd'hui
quelle que soit la classe sociale dans
laquelle vous êtes vous vous sentez
concerné par la question écologique
c'est plus un truc de privilégier ce et
puis ça je fais en tant que militant
écologiste ce phénomène là moi je le
constate depuis très peu de temps depuis
quelques années puis de 2 3 ans et je
crois que ça monte en puissance
la question écologique est une question
sociale et vice versa il n'y a pas de
modèle social tenable dans les temps qui
viennent sans la prise en compte de la
contrainte écologique de la question
écologique c'est-à-dire de la finitude
de la planète
non non pour l'instant non mais vous
savez on est dans un moment politique de
perdition
je peux être trop long mais depuis 50
ans depuis l'après-guerre même il ya
deux grandes forces politiques qui en
occident
ce partage interne hâtivement le pouvoir
la droite de gouvernement
en gros la gauche de gouvernement elles
ont beaucoup de différence mais elles
ont un point commun c'est qu'elle
construise tous leurs projets de progrès
social sur la croissance la croissance
des pib
or la croissance infinie du modèle
actuel de développement dans un monde
fini
ça ne peut plus durer et donc on est à
un moment de rupture des modèles et
politique que nous avions qu'est-ce qui
auront qu est ce qui apparaît l'offre
d'extrême droite sir le populisme
d'extrême droite du rejet de l'autre ce
qui apparaît aussi sous une forme de
populisme de gauche de voilà faut tout
mettre par terre etc etc et ceux qui
essayent de survivre dans le modèle
actuel
ce que j'appelle la synthèse libéral
c'est la gauche de gouvernement et la
droite de gouvernement qui se mettent
ensemble nous on pense que des écolos
que si on veut inventer un avenir
désirable à la planète pour inventer un
autre modèle qui est celui de l'écologie
politique est aujourd'hui dans cette
espèce de brouhaha du paysage politique
auquel on assiste
c'est plus difficile de faire entendre
cette voix mais ce que je constate c'est
qu'en allemagne et pas un petit pays au
niveau européen la deuxième force
politique du pays aujourd'hui ce sont
les verts en belgique
ils vont avoir des élections
législatives nationales en même temps
que les élections européennes
il est possible que nos amis écolos ils
s'appellent écolo en belgique arrive en
tête
est ce que je constate c'est que même en
france il ya un an parce qu'on parle à
ce stade on parle des sondages il ya un
an nous les verts on était à 3%
aujourd'hui on est entre 8 et 9 donc je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose qui est en
train de se matérialiser
il ya notre score à nous mais vous
parliez des autres forces politiques de
la gauche plus traditionnelles qui se
revendique aujourd'hui écolo même
monsieur macron dire regardez moi aussi
j'ai des échos louis-josé veauche
exactement et moi je vois ça comme une
invitation à faire encore mieux dire que
j'ai pas j'ai pas une vision défensive
par rapport à ça il est très bien si
tout le monde parle d'écologie ça me va
maintenant il faut que tout le monde en
face à toute difficulté de europe
écologie et l'erdre parti politique
c'est de voir comme ça régulièrement des
gens s'enfuir a appelé appelé à devenir
à nice a reculé à venir
est ce que c'est parce que ses soucis
inhérents aux besoins d'autres parties
est ce que c'est des aventures
individuelles est ce que c'est parce que
vous êtes une sont évités par son parti
et pour vous avez bien dit les choses
pour internet il ya un peu bon il ya les
turpitudes individuels tels ou tels
opportunisme bon ça c'est la vie c'est
pas spécifiquement on verse arrive mais
un autre sujet compte est d'ailleurs
très justement c'est que vous savez les
verts quand ils sont construits c'était
dans l'adversité tout le monde pensait
que le modèle de développement de la
croissance ça allait durer toujours
et nous on était des soldes on était des
sortes de choux quand écologie politique
arrive au début des années 70 il ya ce
qu'on appelle le club de rome et qui
disent ils font une étude sur les
limites de la croissance alors en pleine
de trente glorieuses on nous regarde
avec des yeux écarquillés en dire mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ces fous qui
nous disent que va y avoir du changement
climatique que la biodiversité va se
détruire personnes croyant ça donc on
s'est construit c'est vrai avec des
identités lasserre individuel très
résilient très combative etc etc est
muté de cette histoire laquelle un autre
et qu'il faut assumer que je revendais
qu'ils ont je suis fier à une force
politique qu'assume l'exercice du
pouvoir de dire maintenant nous sommes
plus les marginaux et les minoritaires
nous sommes ceux qui avons contribué pas
tout seul cas vont contribuer à
convaincre la société que la question
écologique était était fondamental est
donc là il ya une nécessité pour nous de
franchir un niveau d'être meilleur que
nous avons été et donc je pense que
depuis vous savez trois quatre ans on a
un peu guérite ce à dire que les copains
les gens continuent la partie nord de ce
qu'ils étaient bien partis
pascal durand et pascal canfin ce qui
est étrange la liste l'appliquant ne
récupère que ça fait quatre ans qu'ils
sont plus à europe ecologie les verts
donc nous finissons de solder cette
période là qui a aussi été une plaque de
verre ce qui reste là ils iront pas si
vous voulez je pense qu'on a clarifié
on a clarifié les choses politiquement
cirque eux il ya un moment où parmi les
écolos aux existait des écolos de droit
des écolos libéraux des écolos gauche de
la gauche des écolos
environnementalistes etc je pense que ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on a clarifié
ceux qui pensaient que l'écologie est
compatible pour faire vite avec la
croissance et le capitalisme
ils sont partis a priori donc là
aujourd'hui
il ya aussi les gens qui nous rejoignent
avec le mouvement pour le climat est
aussi ça faisait longtemps qu'on avait
pas des personnes qui rejoignait europe
ecologie les verts dont je constate moi
plutôt ça sur une ligne politique qui
vous voyez le plus clair pire que on se
fait on se fixe pas par rapport à la
droite par rapport à la gauche
on assume une identité politique
spécifique dans le paysage actuel que le
mot de la situation d'europe écologie
les verts à la réunion en vue des
prochaines échéances
et si le secrétaire régional aujourd'hui
un show et d'élus sur une majorité avec
le maire de saint-denis qui tue tout à
fait incompatible avec un soutien de
l'okano écouter fera franc-parler avait
que moi je vais pas faire d'ingérence là
dedans après si vous êtes secrétariat
sera pas lui mais nous sommes à parti
voulait dit très régionaliste donc moi
je respecte les identités et les choses
niveau j'allais je pense pas qu'en 2015
aux dernières élections 2014 puis
conseiller municipal le maire actuel
était déjà ma chronique puisque à
l'époque monsieur macro et avec monsieur
roland il était socialiste
voilà donc ils font alors après je vous
le dis on est dans un paysage je compte
pas spécifiquement de la réunion la
politique mouvant nous que nous
défendrons à la réunion comme ailleurs
c'est sur une forme de plateforme
qu'est ce qu'on veut faire au niveau
local et moi je suis très attaché
un concept qu'un train de se développer
avec beaucoup de force en tout cas avoir
métropole sur l'idée de municipal isme
de comment on construit des projets au
delà des étiquettes sur des projets de
développement locaux sur encore une fois
de l'économie locale comme on associe
les citoyennes et les citoyens non
seulement la prise de décision mais
également à leur mise en oeuvre
je crois que c'est la voie de l'avenir
on a besoin de reprendre pied avec la
réalité de nos territoires et nos
citoyens qui ont perdu et qui sont en
train de perdre à vitesse grand v
confiance en leurs représentants
politiques
c'est aussi le rôle des partis
politiques de dire on fait pas pour vous
on fait pas à votre place vous votez pas
une fois pour nous tous les six ans et
après on s'occupe de tout pour s'en
sortir c'est ensemble et donc faut qu'on
fasse ensemble
moi j'espère que ça sera dans des
projets de ce type là que mes amis
écologistes à la réunion et ailleurs
vont s'impliquer pour les élections
municipales puis pour les élections
régionales
on arrive en toute fin d'émission un mot
sur votre
espoir de ce corps ici puisque geneviève
payet qui la reine de l'état rien
position inéligible à vie débute en mai
blague à part j'espère qu'on va gagner
j'espère vraiment qu'on va gagner je
pense qu'on est à un moment politique ou
l'europe peut changer le centre de
gravité politique j'ai dit qu'en
allemagne les verts était très haut dans
les sondages
imaginez que si en france et en
allemagne les deux forces politiques
créé la surprise ce sont les verts ça
change de visage de l'europe
ça changera le visage de l'europe donc
moi c'est à cela qu'on travaille donc
j'espère qu'on fera le meilleur score
possible j'aime pas donner un chiffre
parce qu'évidemment voilà mais je dis
même un truc encore plus ambitieux
j'espère qu'on gagnera par contre en
tête
merci david cormand d'avoir été l'invité
de lundi politique sur la première
bientôt par une musique avec soin
la première à st 2 90 points 7
[Musique]
12h15 à 13h le club de la presse sur la
première on va parler des élections
européennes qui sont d'accord sur rien
shop in shop
il faut pas croire y avait une vraie
tentative de conjonction entre 0,20 et
qu'on soit pour ou contre moi je vous
dis je suis ni pour ni contre le club de
la presse tous les mardis de 12h15 à 13h
avec gueye le dantec sur la première
haute et la réunion la 11e édition des
nuits son lumière et lancé du 8 avril au
2 mai par le parc national
soutenus par plus de 100 partenaires
vous aussi mobilisez vous pour réduire
la pollution lumineuse favoriser l'envol
des pétrels et la ponte des tortues
marines
retrouvez le programme d extinction et
animations sur nuit sans lumière point
est re les nuits sans lumière à fait
noir pour i télé en noir lors une
opération du parc national de la seor et
du cce
bonjour j'ai essayé ou même comment
arrêter l'ordinateur je crois que j'ai
fait une bêtise et la donne un petit peu
des titres à écouter tout à l'heure
alors par exemple lowen oui mais l'étude
de qui maintenant je ne peux pas
connaître ce nouvel album
alors si je vous dis je t'aime à
l'italienne
ah ben là c'est pas pareil ben oui ben
oui c'est les deux f c'est pas ça avec
sonia une grosse surprise m'ont dit pas
si on a l'impression d'y aller on sait
déjà sur ma page facebook
ouais fredo sera avec nous en direct
soit paix lui ferez tout comme ses
camarades tout le monde sa maladie fredo
c'est le chanteur de l'amour ne peut pas
faire autrement frédéric françois avec
nous en direct pendant l'émission mais
ça sera à partir de 14 heures et de 14 à
15 ans il sera là pour répondre à vos
questions pour vous écouter bah lui dire
combien vous l'aimez convient de
concerts à laquelle vous avez assisté
si vous avez des autographes de frédéric
françois un très très bel album de 12
titres qui vient juste de paraître pour
fêter ses 50 ans de carrière
s'ils me donnent les titres il faut
mieux les écouter parce que c'est pas
très cool à la police si quoi que les
fans ils ont déjà l'album il ya elle est
chargée parce que maintenant c'est comme
ça ça va vite
voilà juste un peu d'amour c'est ce qui
cartonne en ce moment parce que c'est le
titre de l'album voilà merci sagna merci
j'ai joué demain solaire de valeur avec
frédéric françois
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
merci à vous d'avoir choisi la première
il est 13 heures
[Musique]
mais l'heure des titres du journal de la
rédaction de france info
deux mois de consultations et 2 millions
de contributions plus tard le
gouvernement tire les conclusions du
grand débat national ce matin edouard
philippe doit faire un discours à midi
les cinq gars ans se sont exprimés le
regrette que les thèmes étaient est
fixée par le chef de l'état il rappelle
qu'il faut faire attention aux chiffres
parmi les propositions la baisse des
impôts